[Musik]
maly in westafrika hier wird gefeiert
was das zeug hält trotz krone
das ist ein pandemie die gibt es hier in
afrika
vielleicht brauche ich in europa und
damit genieße und herzlich willkommen zu
dieser folge von dem ich stehe vor einem
der heißesten angesagten nachtclub in
bamako mali
hier treffen die leute interessanter und
das inmitten einer party wie zur hölle
ist das möglich ich bin jetzt kurz davor
nach bamako zu fliegen
am flughafen in paris ich will wissen
was ist da los in mali welche rolle
spielt corona dort und warum ist
unbeschwertes feiern dort möglich
während hier bei uns alles dicht ist
ich habe die komplette partie in
deutschland verbracht aber ich habe
viele friends in westafrika ihre
instagram stories haben mich zum teil
richtig neidisch gemacht auch deshalb
möchte ich nach mali um zu sehen wie es
ist mal wieder so richtig zu feiern
die korona krise hat die ganze welt
getroffen
in nord und südamerika steigen die
todeszahlen unaufhörlich auf europa
steckt mittlerweile in der zweiten welle
für den kontinent afrika hatten
expertinnen zu beginn der pandemie
katastrophale entwicklungen
prognostiziert doch nach all dem was sie
bei uns mit bekommen sieht es zumindest
in westafrika ganz anders aus hat man
dort die krankheit wirklich im griff das
möchte ich herausfinden
angekommen in bamako
es ist heiß und schwül um einzureisen
brauchte ich ein negatives testergebnis
dass keine 72 stunden altes am flughafen
in bamako wird direkt meine temperatur
gemessen und alle paar meter muss sich
desinfektions gehe auftragen
es gibt auch überall
sensibilisierungskampagnen in mali sind
seit ausbruch der pandemie etwas mehr
als 100 menschen an cholera gestorben
offiziell infiziert haben sich knapp
8000 menschen
aber wie verlässlich sind diese zahlen
fest steht mali hat sehr schnell
reagiert am 18 märz kam der harte
lockdown die schulen und geschäfte
blieben geschlossen es gab
ausgangssperren alle grenzen waren sich
das ganze dauerte zwei monate lang
wir gehen jetzt ins haus das ist eine
schar von zwei freundinnen und die wurde
renoviert und die machen jetzt wieder
auf heute
in der bar trifft sich die mittel- und
oberschicht aus der hauptstadt
ich kann hier einen ersten eindruck
bekommen zumindest von den
wohlhabenderen milieu wie locker sind
die menschen hier wirklich und was
denken sie über die pandemie
desinfizieren am eingang ist schon mal
pflicht
hey wie gehts dir geht super
freud nicht glückwunsch zu
die shisha café betreiberin bibi hofft
dass später noch richtig voll wird
schließlich lebt sie ja von den business
die malerin hat auch verwandten in
frankreich
das letzte mal war sie im frühling hat
nach zehn tagen habe ich es nicht mehr
ausgehalten
da musste ich zurück nach hause nach
mali ich meinte zu meiner mutter mein
hein ist schon putzig ich gehe wieder
nach hause die bis bar ist inzwischen
rappelvoll
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber ich
kann meinen augen nicht trauen hat sich
diese bilder sehe er hat hier niemand
angst vor der ansteckung
am anfang hatte ich schon angst aber aus
der ferne
das war so eine krankheit aus europa das
war eine krankheit für die weißen würde
ich sagen
man kann sich ja hier schützen mit einer
maske zum beispiel trage ich jetzt zwar
nicht aber
man sagt ihr dass er weiß wo diese
krankheit bekommen als schwarze viele
denken sie in afrika dass man es kriegen
kann man mit weißem in berührung kommt
liebe leute glauben hier also dass seine
krankheit für weiße ja ehrlich gesagt
schon fast alle hier glauben dass dort
und da gibt es einfach viel mehr fälle
corona eine krankheit der weißen das
werden wir noch öfter hören in diesem
film
[Musik]
ich will auf die andere seite des landes
sehen denn mali ist ein sehr armes land
vor allem außerhalb der städte dorthin
zu fahren ist zu gefährlich
denn im norden malis herrscht seit 2012
bürgerkrieg immer wieder kommt es zu
terroranschlägen
daher bleibe ich in der hauptstadt hier
auf dem markt in bamako kann ich einen
kleinen eindruck davon bekommen wie es
auf dem land aussehen muss die menschen
erledigen hier ihre wochen einkäufe die
lebensmittelkosten umgerechnet wenige
cent
[Musik]
denn in bamako herrscht keine offizielle
masken pflicht im freien ist das tragen
der maske freiwillig
das einzige mittel das mali im kampf
gegen die pandemie hat ist der harte
lockdown und davor haben die menschen
hier riesige angst ich finde das sinnlos
das alles wegen po wird geschlossen wird
das ist für uns verkäuferinnen keine
gute sache krankheit oder nicht wir
haben keine wahl wir müssen überleben
ich glaube nicht an diese krankheit weil
ich noch nie jemanden gesehen habe der
das hat ich glaube nicht daran
überhaupt nicht
anstatt ärztinnen vertrauen viele
menschen hier er den kräuterkunde
erinnern die auf dem markt ihre
heilkräuter und wurzeln verkaufen
ich komme zu dir und dann sage ich mich
ab die grippe mir geht es nicht gut und
du sagst du ich hab da etwas für dich
dann gibst du mir das hier aber was
genau mache ich mit diesem kraut das mit
anderen pflanzen und mit zitrone kann
dir helfen ok mit zitrone zitrone aber
wie nimmt man das kriegt man das wie ein
t und dann trägt das morgens mittags und
abends
aber was ist die kombination um kurven
zu bekämpfen
das ist dasselbe kraut zusammen mit
einem anderen kraut unten zitrone die
drei sachen machen
in ländern wie mali gehören kräuterkunde
rinnen zum täglichen leben dazu und
gegen erkältungen und die symptome
vieler krankheiten helfen die
pflanzlichen wirkstoffe auf aber dass
das corona virus durch kräuter mit
zitrone bekämpft werden kann ist
wissenschaftlich natürlich nicht wenn du
die chance hättest den impfstoff zu
nehmen gegen krohne würdest du das
machen niemals niemals niemals sicher
ich glaube nicht an das was sie weiß zu
machen
die sind zu allem in der lage mit
meißeln ist für mich eine labor
krankheit wenn es darum geht geld zu
verdienen sind die weißen aber zu allem
fähig ich würde mich nicht impfen lassen
es gibt nicht nur vorurteile und
misstrauen sondern oft schlicht gar
keinen zugang zu konventioneller medizin
das gesundheitssystem in mali ist sehr
sehr schwach es gibt nur vier große
kliniken im ganzen land zur erinnerung
hier leben 20 millionen menschen
ich fahre in die gabriel zur klinik hier
stehen fünf der zehn beatmungsgeräte in
mali überhaupt al mustafa mega ist einer
der führenden virologen in mali und
forscht seit jahren zu epidemien er ist
mitverantwortlich für den frühen
lockdown im märz der die ausweitung von
cobit bis heute gering halten konnte
als erstes will ich wissen was er von
den kräutern denkt die ich auf dem markt
gekauft habe die seien tatsächlich sehr
wirksam gegen viele krankheiten nur eben
nicht gegen das corona wir im kampf
gegen die pandemie ist für dr mega ein
ganz anderer punkt entscheidend
also wenn jemand infiziert ist nehmen
wir die daten von der ganzen familie den
freunden von allen kontaktpersonen der
letzten fünf tage
wir nehmen die nummer von jeder
einzelnen personen und dann geben wir
den eine nummer hier müssen sie jeden
tag anrufen damit wir sehen können ob
sie symptome wie fieber hat
das müssen sie drei bis vier tage lang
machen infektionsketten streng
nachverfolgen und ein direkter harter
lockdown das hat einmal ich schon einmal
funktioniert im oktober 2014 hat es mal
mit derselben konsequenz geschafft die
ebola epidemie einzudämmen nur acht
fälle gab es hier
obwohl die am schlimmsten betroffenen
länder wie guinea sierra leone und
liberia in direkter nachbarschaft liegen
auch damals hat die regierung schnell
die schulen geschlossen kontakte
nachverfolgt kranke schnell isoliert und
so das fragile gesundheitssystem
geschützt
corona pandemie halten viele hier ja
aber führt da nicht so ein großes
problem für eine krankheit der weichen
habe ich immer wieder gehört dieses
gericht ordnete dr
wir haben gelernt dass diese krankheit
für junge menschen nicht sehr gefährlich
ist es besonders für ältere menschen
gefährlich und für menschen die mehrere
krankheiten haben wie bluthochdruck
diabetes übergewicht
diese art von probleme gibt es bei uns
nicht so wie in den usa oder europa
ich habe den virologen auch auf die test
kapazitäten angesprochen
in mali wird vor allem auf dem land viel
viel weniger getestet als bei uns in der
hauptstadt dagegen seien die
infektionszahlen relativ verlässlich so
dr hier gibt es sogar gratis testzentren
wie dieses hier ein wichtiger grund es
gibt hier einfach super viele junge
leute in man das durchschnittsalter
liegt bei 16,3 jahre
umso wichtiger ist es hier dass das
soziale leben stattfindet wie auch das
musikfestival bama ort eine riesige
veranstaltung
ok also hier werden die leute noch mal
richtig aufgeheizt und zwar kriegst du
mit einem ticket umsonst ich dachte mir
aber müsse man den mann alkoholisiert
das heißt da ist kein alkohol trinkt
denn man mir eines muslimischer staat
und zu filmen
ein energydrink damit sie es richtig
das festival findet alle drei monate
statt
auf dem gelände befinden sich
schätzungsweise 8000 menschen
sie kommen aus jeder schicht denn der
eintritt ist mit umgerechnet 1 euro 50
pro person
ziemlich niedrigen ich staunen nicht
schlecht so was habe ich gefühlt ewig
nicht mehr erlebt aber hier geht es
nicht nur um das vergnügen der besucher
innen wie die performer die bald auf der
bühne stehen werden geht es um die
existenz
sie treffen einen kurz vor seinem
auftritt guten haben zimmer das fenster
ja ich stelle mich vor ich bin g
paradies zu gangs mein leben das ist
mein live ich liebe dich mama
wir haben keine wahl
das problem ist einfach dass wir
arbeiten müssen wir müssen einfach die
künstler und solche events schützen
das ist extrem wichtig
ok danke ich wünsche dir viel erfolg mit
deiner karriere auf dem festival
performen die größten stars aus gabun
turbo senegal der ganzen
französisch-sprachigen afrikanischen
welt auch deshalb versucht mal die
solche events so lange wie möglich zu
schützen
anders als in deutschland wo
mittlerweile ja viele künstlerinnen vor
dem aus stehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was für ein cooler abend der morgen
danach ich treffe den betreiber abandon
von wahrheit und ich möchte meine
perspektive auf das ganze in afrika
genauer gesagt dem maly sieht die
realität ganz anders aus
wir kriegen 0 hilfe vom staat wir leben
von tag zu tag
ja es ist gefährlich aber du bist ja
trotzdem zu uns gekommen oder nicht es
ist gefährlich
ja klar ernsthaft ich habe angst um mich
und die anderen aber was soll ich machen
wir müssen leben überleben wir müssen
uns dann die krankheit anpassen
also wenn du mir jetzt die frage stellst
vor hunger sterben oder im coop mit 19
sterben model das nicht einfach um den
tod auszuweichen muss man in jedem fall
die krankheit bekämpfen aber muss halt
auch arbeiten
ich verstehe
solange die zahl so niedrig sind sie
seitdem lockdown muss hier alles offen
bleiben und wir können ganz legal feiern
apropos heute ist ari das geburts
verklagt und ich darf mit kras nach zehn
monaten dickel in zug wie werde ich mich
wohl fühle
[Musik]
katharina bibi und ihre freundinnen
feiern bis in die nacht und ich komme
aus dem staunen nicht braun
ein heftiges gefühl die pandemie habe
ich für ein paar stunden vergessen
und ehrlich gesagt hab mir das auch
ziemlich gut am nächsten tag geht es für
nicht wieder zurück nach deutschland und
zurück in den lok tor
ich habe hier in mali wirklich
aufregende tage erlebt und verstanden
die einzige maßnahme die mali hat ist
einfach der schnelle und harte lockt
sonst könnte alles kollabieren
konsequent hat molly fünf tage nach
meinem besuch auch wieder alles
zugemacht denn die zahlen waren wieder
leicht angestiegen
jedenfalls wünsche ich allen gilt dass
das diesmal wieder so gut klappen wird
wie im frühjahr so das war's auch schon
wieder mit dieser folge von trending
wenn ich gemacht habe
dann abonniert den kanal auf youtube
findet ihr bestimmt hier irgendwo
eingeblendet noch andere folgen von
ständig habt ihr schon mal von anderen
staaten gehört außerhalb deutschland
wurden die besser leute sind zu holen wo
man solche großen partys waren schreibt
mir das bitte in die kommentare
und wir sehen uns am nächsten video
[Musik]